Hey youtubers it's Charlie and the Arrow producers
just revealed a bunch of details about season
3.
Black Canary is back, there's going to be
a time jump and all you oilicity shippers
will be really happy.
So this is going to be a breakdown explaining
everything.
Hello any new people, if you're finding me
for the first time I do arrow and doc videoed
every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll explain my comic con giveaway at the
end of all this season 3 craziness.
So right off the bat let's talk about where
Season 3 is starting off in the timeline.
It's not going to pick up right after they
Stuck Slade in the Argus Prison at the end
of Season 2.
It will jump forward in time several months.
The producers didn't give an exact number,
but it's more than 6.
Enough time has passed that Oliver is basically
in chill mode as the Arrow and the rest of
the Team is enjoying a time out from the shitstorm
that was Manu Bennett.
Arrow and The Flash both have this thing where
they kind of follow a real life timeline.
Stephen Amell, Emily Bett, Colton and David
Ramsay go on hiatus for like 6 months, Team
Arrow goes on hiatus for 6 months.
It's what they're doing during this break
period that everyone was going crazy about
this week.
In the official synopsis for Episode 1 titled
"The Calm" Oliver totally asks Felicity out
on a date.
And all of a sudden the Olicity fandom cries
out in triumph.
Big asterisk though.
But still it's funny to think the show is
going there.
It just proves that a massive tumblr campaign
works.
High Fives to all you Olicity gif makers out
there.
That first episode takes a bit of a left turn
with their supposed romance, but the rest
of the season will address their relationship.
The words used to describe the situation were,
Oliver will explore his feelings for Felicity,
he'll actually try to process whether he has
real feelings or if it's something else.
And he'll make Felicity aware of that.
The moment they shared on the beach was totally
real, if you saw the way they were looking
at each other, that wasn't a trick or anything.
There was a lot of sexual tension, way more
than normal.
And now that Slade isn't trying to chop their
heads off they can deal with it.
Thus we get our Episode 1 Olicity date.
Let me explain the giant asterisk with that.
In case you didn't see recently, Stephen Amell
and Marc Guggenheim were tweeting pictures
of the set while they were filming the first
episode.
There's a whole lot going on in these so some
of it I'll talk about in a future video.
But they're basically at a fight.
That's probably here Oliver takes Felicity
on their super date.
The funny thing is that this feels like something
Oliver enjoys that he thinks Felicity would
enjoy, but really I don't see Felicity being
a huge sports fan.
It's that thing where you get someone else
a gift that's for them, but you didn't take
the time to think if it's something they would
be into.
That sounds like something Oliver would do.
Derp.
Even if the boxing ring isn't from their date.
And because of all the blowup doll extras
I kind of think it is.
This could be a big easter egg for the Ted
Grant Wildcat.
He hasn't been announced for this season,
but in the comics, that character was a big
part of the Justice Society and he was a boxer
before becoming a superhero.
I'll totally do a bonus video for him soon.
In the episode one description it basically
tees up a new villain barging into Starling
City and messing up their date.
It doesn't sounds like the Count Vertigo since
he's supposed to be a drug dealer and the
villain is described as the second villain.
Meaning I think he's going to be more like
the Brother Blood character.
A medium bad while Peter Stormare who's a
pretty big actor, will be the biggest villain.
The mercenary character is targeting people
associated with a certain company.
I guess they want to maintain some mystery
but I think he's targeting people associated
with Queen Industries.
Not necessarily Oliver.
But it's possible that Count Vertigo hired
the mercenary to keep Team Arrow busy while
he peddles his wares.
The next big Season 3 reveal is that Black
Canary is back.
I know WTF, what's going on?
At the end of season 2 she got on the boat
to return with Nyssa and the League to Nanda
Parbat.
The explanation is that it's the mercenary
killer, this new villain that brings her back.
He or she is supposedly wanted for killings
in several countries.
So either Sarah has been tracking them or
she comes back to intercept.
Caity Lotz has not been reported as a cast
regular like John Barrowman and the other
new characters, Brandon Routh and Peter Stormare.
What does that mean for the Canary?
She'll probably just be in a few episodes
unless she's just in the first one.
I don't think they'll be making Laurel put
on the black leather anytime soon, so keeping
Sarah around longer is just another way to
stall that transformation.
I was a big fan of Caity Lotz in season 2,
I don't think she got a lot of screen time,
but she was a nice addition to Team Arrow.
I'm interested to see if her re-appearance
complicates the Oliver Felicity romance.
Like the writers want there to be people from
all sides making it almost impossible for
Oliver and Felicity to address what's really
going on between them.
On Felicity's side of things, Brandon Routh's
new Atom character is going to be one of the
new 'ships.
He'll basically be like a more sciency version
of Oliver, which is Felicity's domain on the
show.
So I think she's going to have even better
chemistry with him.
It's all part of the process of tearing Team
Arrow apart during the season, then putting
it back together at the end.
Like right now they're riding high and super
close, so the new story in season 3 will slap
them around like last year and then by the
end.
They'll be made whole again and become stronger
from the experience.
I know that sounds super simple, but it's
the same basic journey for all heroes.
So what's up with the rest of the big characters?
A lot of you guys asked me about Detective
Lance, at the end of last season he was basically
dying in the street.
Because of that time jump I mentioned, he's
fully recovered and he's become Captain now.
So he and Oliver are going to have much more
of a Batman Gordon relationship.
And now Quentin will have the power to actually
help him.
Where the season picks up, the city acknowledges
the Arrow as a hero.
So he's not a vigilante they're hunting down
anymore.
Moving on to Roy, he's settling in to his
Arsenalt persona pining away for Thea.
He's been de-powered, but Oliver never had
powers, so Roy will just be salmon laddering
his ass into shape next to him every day.
The addition of Brandon Routh to Team Arrow
is going to be an interesting wrinkle in Roy
and Oliver's relationship.
I actually think it will bring them closer
together.
Roy's personality is a lot closer to Oliver's
than Ray Palmer's, so I think he'll identify
with Oliver even after The Atom joins team
Arrow.
They are introducing Brandon Routh's character
in the first couple of episodes.
But think of it as like a modified Isabel
Rochev arc.
Ray Palmer, his character, is taking over
Queen Industries.
Palmer's company buys them out, so he's Oliver's
new boss.
I'm sure your'e all imagining the funny boardroom
scenes where he shushes Oliver in front of
Felicity.
They haven't revealed when Palmer will become
the Atom or if he'll already have the gear
when he shows up.
It feels like seeing him develop the persona
would be too much fun to waste.
So I really hope we get to see the transformation
by the mid-season finale.
On the flipside let's not forget Malcolm Merlyn
and Thea.
He's a cast regular, so he's going to be in
most of the episodes.
But it's unclear what his arc is going to
be.
Whether he's going to try and rebuild his
empire or just seek revenge on everyone.
Last year Stephen Amell said that Oliver and
Merlyn had a lot of unfinished business.
So I think after Dark he'll be taking jabs
at Oliver and during the day he'll be taking
on Ray Palmer and the new Queen Industries
company.
Remember, Merlyn lost his company too.
So just like Oliver he might be looking to
get it back.
I feel like we got cheated out of a Merlyn
Oliver team up in the season 2 finale.
So I really hope that John Barrowman just
becomes the Loki of the series, jumping back
and forth between helping and hurting Team
Arrow.
The rest of the characters I think I'll wait
till after Comic Con to talk about, just because
we'll get a lot more information there.
For everyone asking.
Yes I will be at the panel and I will upload
footage.
Be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff.
During the week of comic con I'll be posting
a bunch of the panels.
I have a link in the description you can use
to vote on which ones you want the most.
It will help me prioritize which stuff I post
first.
They will be screening footage from Season
3, but unless they post it online after the
panel.
I won't be able to upload that part.
I'll keep you guys posted on all that.
Here's what's going on with my Arrow giveaway.
Starting right now, you can enter to win a
copy of the arrow season 2 blu ray or dvd,
your choice.
It's not on sale till september.
So you get a pre-order.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
I'll leave the giveaway open till the week
after comic con.
Tonight I'm posting a bonus Flash video explaining
all the different versions of the Reverse
Flash.
I'll try to get that up by 8 or 9PM.
You can click here to get that, I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and click
here to learn all about Brandon Routh's Atom
Character
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!